did you poop we're on vacation to Puerto
Varas to Mexico and we decided to try
some Mexican McDonald's let's do it whoa
what is this
welcome Olli whoo it really does look
fancier than vamanos from the US it also
has pico de gaia which I'm really
excited
American McDonald's like the bread just
is like a sponge the bread definitely
tastes a lot more hearty it's very
cheesy
I wouldn't devour this it's like a mix
between a burrito and a burger mmm-hmm
the flavors are very down home I love
like Mexican flavor in one burger when
you can't decide between like Mexican
food or like American food that would be
a good option in the sauce counter they
also had salsa verde and chimichurri Oh
spicy it's not spicy but it's a very
interesting flavor what really takes it
to the next level are these sauces oh is
that some barbecue sauce it smells so
good right off the bat a bunch of crispy
things inside to you bacon fried onions
hmm it's a lot sweeter than I expected
I'm not a huge fan of like fried things
but I would eat that burger Oh what are
these fried onions see this is a little
too much for me we're getting too crazy
it's a little too sweet though I
character barbecues just like
overwhelming it's a lot I love things
that are savory but a little bit yeah
this one was gesso pie so what I've
never heard of this item I'm intrigued
it's really good soft long it's really
good it literally is just like
cheesecake or floating stuffing a pie
and it's delicious and I love McDonald's
apple pies but this was really really
good oh I love potato what we have
potato wedges in the US but not in
McDonald's mmm these are incredible I
wish McDonald's in the US I'd be you
it's hard to mess up potato wedges and
they definitely have not messed these up
we think back to like school lunches you
ever talk about your school lunches and
they were clearly way better than any
impossible jalapeno cheese - oh my gosh
so different there's so many good things
kind of remind me of donut holes doesn't
taste like a tornado yep it's like
string cheese deep-fried that's really
good I love those flavors cheese and
jalapeno Chi reminds me of like nacho
cheese with like jalapeno juice mixed
into it I don't know if I could do this
I see you with my McDonald's really I
get it but the cheese is good
my name is party later I head that is my
new best friend since I've been in
Mexico do you know what it is it's like
carob le
caramelize goat milk mmm it's really
refreshing even though it's really sweet
look at how tiny it see they care about
our health u.s. McFlurry they're like ah
I just like I hit that cuz it gives you
like nice like aftertaste so I feel the
dance here eating this if you're here ml
lover you'll like this my favorite thing
was the cheese get so high that case of
fire was amazing I really enjoy the walk
mode that you want we just put like a
spread of that chimichurri sauce
I really like the chimichurri sauce and
how well it goes with everything the
cheese balls in the wedges were so good
I could eat those all day every time I
have international McDonald's it's
always slightly better than you at
McDonald's they just have higher
standards now I'm gonna go eat my cheese
balls and she's basically yeah
[Music]